all right but we have finally live
apologies all right well you got a king
we got takes a lot they get a business
first so I am very obviously aka Lord
[ __ ] needle of the iron Lords podcasts
and this is also part of the Lords of
gaming gaming network and this is my PAX
East submission for 2019
my name is Arliss James Lewis I'm aka
Lord addict part of the iron Lords
podcast as well as the lord's gaming
Network and this is my practice my
submission to PAX East there we go so
yeah there we go
2019 I forgot to you my name is Brian
Andujar aka Lord sovereign of the iron
Lords podcast and also a member of the
Lords of gaming network and this is my
lord King David Lords of gaming network
this is my life alright welcome to the
Isle of podcast episode 94 and it's
another glorious Sunday we are back at
the round table and the Lord's Day well
was extremely excited about our special
guest he can make it in progress but
we've got the Bungie and Activision
split Division two in the epic store CES
wrap up and ranking the success of the
PlayStation 4 and spider-man to discuss
so we gonna get right into it so let's
introduce the Four Horsemen of gaming
those usual suspects here at the round
table is my co-host still with us
because he may be going to alright but
let's do is intro anyway
Marco Holmes with the cold most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game Conqueror and the half of
the young wolf mommy operating on 1%
power Lord addict hold er hold O Lord I
just got that of Ravan was said to me
Lord maka is coming in five minutes we
go still do I eat rose and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo game or the single-player
experience and also mister I'm good
[Music]
absolutely right anything I played this
week you will to demo tell me about that
will talk about that demo so I played it
three times because I want to play it on
PSN Xbox and PC every time I got a
little further because I knew what was
in front of that King is
just the fact they got back just like
Resident Evil seven did they got back
real survival horror when you're walking
through this very tight corridor there's
no light around you only a flashlight
and zombies come out at you and then the
thing about it is it's they come out at
you and a you can't ever be sure how
many shots is gonna take somebody down
everybody else so you have to either
choose to fight or run which is real
that that is survival horror you know
murder and everybody um and just the
fact that you have to like when it comes
to aiming and stuff like that
you're not stationary you're damaged
it's what you said that song because I'm
so used to like aim assist their
Resident Evil and I'm like oh my shoot
the hit detection on the head is crazy
but I also noticed this right and I
think it's probably intentional that the
pistol is made to feel weak yeah yeah
right like but you know you don't feel
secure with it like normally in games
when you get a pistol is around a game I
got these boots right and I got the
pistol know what it takes ten shots to
drop a Samba show burn you tearing up
all parts of his face and teeka's flat
their head sometimes is one shot for the
head sometimes it's like four shots for
the hey if you can crack their cranium
no but the thing is that that doesn't
necessarily ensure the kill either even
though I blew somebody's head up and I
he was laid out and I'm like okay he's
done I went to a room came and he was
there ready for me I'm away it was
respawn no it was the same dude when you
head off he wasn't completely headless
but the top of his head was going home
oh wow it's funny you said it cuz I had
the same issue like I would body
somebody you emptied a clip and then you
walk past your money and then they're
still coming
extra novel attention to the situations
I'm I'm with your that is not guaranteed
I also got a question the whole game was
there what they did they managed to not
do that they based they set a cutoff
point for the demo right so if once you
play like whatever two or three times
you know what to do and you run through
it and you actually finish the content
of the demo yeah it's gonna shut you
down regardless so yeah I don't think
it's in there no somebody found out the
fraud we didn't go off I literally woke
up like 40 seconds ago it's great no
worries man nobody's so happy to have
you back so be that you're in the room
it's only right we give more market a
proper introduction like the Lord to do
are you ready sir I am very excited for
this all right here we go
I would introduce a lord who I've had
the pleasure of meeting in the flesh on
two separate occasions well at e3 2017
and 2018 now whether this Lord set the
gold standard when it comes to detailed
game guides tutorials and achievement
hunting but also utilizes a clear and
concise teaching style or remaining a
positive ambassador to our gaming
community introducing that creating
hopes of the mocker 91 productions
YouTube channel the Lord of all
collectable guides and reviews and one
of the very few Lords to survive stay
electrics been her and Barbie puppy
rescue for the gamerscore
and Chopra community love from the six
and making his debut into the realm of
the Lords mommy Laura
Patrick maka how you doing sir wow what
an introduction thank you so much
incredible round of applause for you
there oh thank you sir thank you sir
well deserved you are Lord and you're
right it's only right we show you the
proper respect here at the round table
huge fan of yours and it's a pleasure to
have you in the realm how you doing it
great I'm doing fine
that uh that introduction I don't know
it's gonna set the tone for the show for
sure we said it's over we said it so so
we're literally you just read as a
progress with gateways up to Lord saw
we're doing his intro and you were
talking about the Resident Evil 2 demo
did you get a chance to play that I
played a yesterday I decided I got a new
computer so I decided to kind of test
out the the new hardware and run it on
there and put everything up - Mac oh man
that's a demo if I've ever played one
it's great it's fantastic look
spectacular man solve you got any other
comments or yeah I mean at first I
thought I was gonna be really pissed off
with the 30 minute time limit in the
fact you only play it once again but you
can get around that if you have multiple
accounts and stuff like that in
different systems but I think it's you
get just enough have your mouth watering
for the next two weeks like there's so
much like this real quick also I like
the segments where you go from action
and then you go into a dark segment and
he close the camera out it really gets
you into that tension atmosphere and I'm
like man this thing is it's dropping
f-bombs I was like oh let's go and like
you said like he's not like a remaster
just uh it's like they really
we imagine I like I like we told you
I'll he's like when you see one of them
don't you hear but he was looking at you
like I'm like why does he look like he
displeased oh right when I finally got
the knife I tried to freak it like I did
in resi before right before what you
would do is just you pop them in the
kneecap drop them hit it drop then kick
them or hit him with the knife and then
pretty much spam them no that does not
work here not at all anyway so we of
course that's all you've been playing us
off that's much it's been residue that's
pretty much it oh yeah I downloaded
outrun for the switch now go back and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer the Lord of combat
sports was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement Oh beloved Lord King how
you do exist um this week the lone can I
say like information it was a it was a
part where we're picking out our topics
for the show guys
and we're literally got our topics and I
said a fraud topping and I was like I
don't know how to success other switches
doing with no truth with the chat and
then I think was like Thursday we got
bomb after bomb on the harm Mo's lose
and I love that part I love when there's
so much to pick and choose from that the
content of the community you can always
find something else in somebody else's
channel on the topic that you're not
gonna do so you can just run over to
Ryan's channel or you can run over to
dealer's channel or you can run over to
Brad's channel you can run over to
anybody's channel and get a wealth of
information so is enough to go around so
you're not getting regurgitated stuff by
going to other people's channel mm-hmm I
loved that part because I was
anticipating looking at how the
community died sex all this new
information correct no now with that
being said I played this week um back on
destiny because the new lab was open up
you know armory was open up and uh
trying to do the quest line I think
that's for the last word or something
like that what we're trying to do um I
finished the Tomb Raider oh I got to do
how to be like a guy's like a brother
um have to boycott award shows
because if okay let me explain right
award shows focus and highlight games
that are already in the know that are
already there then you know should get
achievements um for the excellence but
then there's other games that are
equally as excellent in that in that
space because I 1200 slow-mo give you
the side out of chat like it's not gonna
resonate which I'm a Tomb Raider fan
I've been playing Tomb Raider since II
once since its inception like every
iteration of Tomb Raider I have purchase
I have played some has been up someone's
been down but these the last remakes on
him I've been along with it I think
they're taking it into a nice space I'm
loving to see Laura grow into the woman
that she's going to be later because
remember we got a finished polished
Laura back on the PlayStation was doing
this thing in the beginning and this
Laura is her learning to beat that Lord
that we had a ring and it's so good and
the 4k I'm like man this game what not
to get any any time alone I heard you
saying yeah it's tough King it is tough
man it was such a good year you know but
I hate what you say it's like to not get
nominee you know how I feel about this
music so I mean I'm with you on these
type of such these subjects but okay so
obsessive key creep Odyssey I'm in the
the stages of you know how you play a
game you waiting for the hook to get
into you like like I go in and
to fall asleep playing it and I'm like
okay I'll wait for the hook to come I go
to our next spot and now I started up so
hopefully this week I can get that done
played a lot of indie games I played the
Resident Evil um
demo mm-hmm and it was it was love it's
it it made me after finish the demo I
had so much resonate with thirst I went
back and played the remake of the first
one Wow
yeah I downloaded that again I need the
guy you guys got the fever that's good
yeah I don't win for and that in the
remake cuz I need my fix yes but the the
the concrete the controls of Resident
Evil 2 the controls is spot-on perfect
feels like a to date game like right now
it feels like this game was made now the
reimagine is beautiful and I went and
played that part one with the tank
controls don't quote me on this protect
I think they do have a modern control
option for the for the remake I think oh
macha did you mess around with the
controls much or how did you feel about
that I tried to play on PC and I'm not a
PC player so it was very interesting
learning they were just clunky enough
that I thought it was because I don't
play normally unhappy and then I was
thinking about plugging in a controller
but I didn't want to waste my time limit
either yeah I just decided to truck
along what stood out to me was like I
was a huge fan of like the classic game
design of like here's the door and
there's a clover on it get the clover
key to open the clover door dummy is the
simple like the simple design of clover
key goes to clover doors I have to like
read a document about who owns this door
and then go find that and then read
through his personal journal to
double-check the nametag to make sure it
goes through they so Todd it's that
simplicity that gave us that joy you
know evacuate a gig so would you get
cake
okay I'm done talking about what I'll
play for a week I'm just happy that
everybody it's telling when everybody
that you run across everybody else on
your friends list either heard about the
demo to to download it to play it or has
played it and I think that's a game
that's gonna probably have a 90% sell
through in a community those numbers
should be really high I think it's gonna
do well I agree cool play the last good
so uh and of course we have the Lord the
cooperative experience and gaming ninja
himself this should no be more kognito
spreading everyone is in the realm of
the ILP not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear you guys
pretty much nailed it I mean same thing
Resident Evil 2 demo
fantastic man really what the feels back
love and attention love and the scary
it's a completely reimagined game I
didn't think I would be as excited as I
was about it to be honest you know say
so I was happy you know they did what
they did did I did a little bit of a
destiny for just as well and I was we
gonna talk about a lot of destiny today
but uh so now that we've gotten into
what the Lords have been playing I want
to start off with Lord Makkah his video
game system history his joy to YouTube
and what eventually led him to become
one of the best collectible guide and
content creators in the game so let's
start from the beginning Lord Makkah
what was some of the first video game
systems you had and what Gatchina gave
me yes I remember like growing up I had
if I didn't have it but my friend had an
n64 and back in those days if your
friend had a system you basically had it
Vienna's house like I don't know three
four times a week playing on 64 we'd
play a lot of gold and I would play a
lot of mario kart diddy kong racing was
probably the game I played the most like
as a young young kid nice and then going
into like my six seven eight years old
ages we got a computer and my parents
found it appropriate that I could play
doom and duke nukem paris on that one
yeah i took that and ran with it and
played a lot of those games and then
eventually own n64 i got
addicted to like Diddy Kong nice then I
got a Dreamcast I was one of the few
people who one of one of the eight
people not out a week we got a puke st i
got a bottle of the system yeah I got it
back you up one time or 64 now what
about I don't know maybe you weren't
into wrestling at that time did you at
least try the wrestling games of the 64
market
I remember them existing I don't
remember if I played them or just like
you saw him at the store he would know
if he played him he would know black
Mouth GameCube had the problem with the
black member it was 64 was the Aki
wrestling games they open call it's like
they're soulless there's no soul in
their mouth you guys maybe wait to the
iconic tree yeah Power Stone on my
fingers from that NFL Blitz smashing the
buttons so hard Crazy Taxi why he's
gotta pay how much is Crazy Taxi the
dream class classic that everyone lost
hours on the demo disc that came with
the gate with the console a little bit
of fishing you played a little bit of
that like weird ass dolphin game yes yes
yo let me tell you a rich out to a
sticker at each an original next level
gaming said maka knows his gaming
dreamcast for life absolutely it was a
crazy underrated console I have only
good things to say about it I don't I
honestly didn't even look into like some
of the reasons it didn't do so well I
hope so maybe it was ahead of its time
because I remember it having like online
connection but who is online gaming in
early 2000 it was it was it the modem
back then yeah the whole side of you had
to call you you know
[Music]
absolutely when you go from the
Dreamcast now did you what did you
transition after the Dreamcast it's
foggy it's [ __ ] man my child remember
having a I don't get the ps1 and ps2 I
had no I had a ps2 and it had an xbox
original Xbox that I got just for Halo
so I think I went from Dreamcast to ps2
but didn't really play it much maybe I
just like you know lost a little bit of
my love for the four games I don't
remember and then I went into the OG
xbox because my friend showed me halo 2
and I was like oh snap this is it chief
and we played it non-stop I I learned to
play inverted because he was playing
inverted he would pass the controller
when he would die
he was much much better than me but I
was determined to get better than him
I played halo 1 on PC a bunch I think
before that maybe is that that gap of
time I forget it maybe
combat Evolved on PC Mag the good old
days nice so you you have you are a PC
game what kind of early no I had no it's
maybe when I described it it sounds like
it but it consists of like maybe three
or three or six months of me as a kid
playing doom on PC and then me for like
six months playing Halo on PC at you
back in the day when like every computer
ran every game and you didn't have to
like have a graphics card and have money
to buy a different from the current rig
you have now yeah back in the day I was
playing like the halo 1 on the PC like
three years after everyone else was
already done playing it I think but
nonetheless moved on to original Xbox
moved on to
I had a Gamecube for a while I really
enjoyed it I played a lot of like the
Madden in the FIFA's in the early 2000s
then I transitioned to the 360 and then
kind of never looked back I've had like
a ps4 and I have a switch now but I I
don't play them much no no doubt makes
tremendous history man so lost our Pete
we had some good friends to the room the
Xbox - and of course Lord reyne the man
with the million games so wanted to talk
to Lord maka about the achievement and
trophy hunting mentality like when did
that aspect start for you and then like
how did that influence you to become one
of the very best god creators in the
game yeah like day one I remember
getting my 360 plugging it in I remember
just like playing I don't remember if it
was Project Gotham or perfect darker
Need for Speed Most Wanted
I think Need for Speed Most Wanted was
the probably the first game that I
really like completed just to get the
achievements might have been a couple
months after that there was a game
called full auto that came out the
February after but I don't I don't know
if I could tell you exactly what it was
but I started unlocking these
achievements I even saw that there was
achieved mint lists there was a
cheapness that I really understand so I
went and I like googled them like most
people would I stumbled across an
achievement forum made some friends in
the community and yeah I kind of just
went from there like I slowly started
making a name for myself like writing
text solutions on this website that
evolved into some people making like
walkthroughs that evolved did some
people making videos that accompany
their walkthroughs hmm and then I got a
capture card and when I got my capture
card I just wanted to show people my
dope halo skills and my guitar hero solo
riffs I've made videos doing that I uh
my first ever video is me like repairing
my controller it's like me repairing it
in one hand me shooting it with like my
point and shoot camera in the other hand
my dog barking in the background oh oh
my life is turned off and it's the
middle of the night so you can't see
what's going on
but I just made a video to like help my
friend fix his controller and and I put
it up on YouTube like just to share with
my friend that kind of cook-off and
started getting views and then I
I don't know everything just kind of
evolved slowly but surely I went to
school and continued doing YouTube as a
hobby and then I came out of school I
needed like a short break from from all
that because I just completely engrossed
myself in school so I needed like a
mental break started doing YouTube more
for in my free time and then it kind of
just took off from there and I don't
know I've never really looked back yeah
you bet it's tremendous story you
literally transition took like one part
of my next question and but yeah prior
to meeting you in the flesh it was at
fan fest 2017 I first met you and then
uh recently last year marks off press
event and I think first time I came
across your content was when we are the
original Xbox one snap feature and we
had the true achievement that embedded
and I think I got stuck finding some
collectibles on like Ryse son of Rome
and like literally every collectible
about it either one of your videos or
hardware tape yeah so how did you get
that like partnership as far as like
with the true achievements in getting
them to kind of link that together cuz I
thought that was really dope yeah so I'm
not really involved in any of that what
happened was there was a website called
xbox360 achievements org a lot of those
members were introduced to true
treatment so a lot of us kind of
participated in both those communities
at the same time and true treatments is
a big like selling point was the fact
that they could like track your gamertag
going through Xbox Live where as 360
achievements wouldn't do that because
it's technically against Xbox rules
which is kind of a scary part I think
it's true treatments could literally get
shut down at any point and I think Xbox
is doing us a solid by keeping us
keeping it up nonetheless that doesn't
matter they could track all the
achievements and and anyone could write
any solution they wanted for any
achievement so I start
kind of writing solutions I started
adding videos to my solutions and and it
kind of took off where you know most of
the videos I make that are related to
anything to an achievement I try to get
them up on that site but like me and
them it's not like we're we haven't
really talked much they're not best
friends but we also are an enemies and
any you know they run their site I run
my stuff I you know we both kind of
complement each other they want the
solutions on there they're you know on
their stuff I want to make my videos and
post them somewhere so it's great it's
great true respect ya know I yeah at
Russia missus dope that's what's up man
I like that I like that yeah man so um I
got a two-part question and this is now
briefly I want to talk briefly about the
txr days only because that's how I came
across you in the podcast on room and as
you already aware like all the Lords of
TX are very near and dear to my heart so
how did the whole process of TX ardently
come together for you that's part one
and then part two you will recently
bestowed the xbox MVP award now I was
setting you up collectors join this
amazing a credible group of these
community leaguers so tell us about
those process the TX are being and then
the Xbox a movie you really tested my
foggy memory in this world let's go TX
alright I don't remember exactly who
even reached out
it was either south or Rand and they
just asked if I wanted to kind of come
on a show and the timing had worked out
where I you know I had the free time so
I was like sure let's do it I think I
came on an episode like seven or eight
hmm and then they kind of just said hey
do you want to come back again next week
in the red alright sure so we just
started doing it every week we started
getting guests invited and working
towards that to do interviews and you
know we just tried to put on the best
show we could for everyone who watched
every week guys
Hilton we grew and we grew and grew and
eventually we reached like you know
people were definitely watching it was
it was it was lovely absolutely man you
got that I mean I consider it one of the
all-star teams of getting together in
for the Xbox community and just gaming
in general very knowledgeable learnt a
lot man love that show so I'm definitely
glad that at least we got a good run you
know he would yeah
yeah very I think the guys wanted to
bring it back I won't be participating
but like I hope it goes great for them I
hope people love the show again
absolutely so let's talk about that Xbox
in VP of war hi today I don't know like
I got nominated someone you know someone
decided to put my name in a hat and
someone drew my name out of that hat I
guess I got an email from Xbox saying
like congrats you won this award so that
or or we'd like to consider you for this
award like let us know what you do for
the community so I you know I explain
like how I make videos I explained how I
put out tweets about about new features
and and how I've worked with Seagate
which is like a company that Xbox is
close to with the hard drives and just
kind of explained like my history with
Xbox and and they decided that I should
be awarded the award so I came came in
the mail like and I get to go to to
Redmond to to see the campus yes for you
oh that's no dad have you been to the
camera so he's your first agree first
I've been to Seattle I've not been to
the campus no yeah I'm trying to we try
to get to go there this year and I dad's
definitely on the bucket list so I
expect pictures of the full report I
take pictures of what I'm allowed to
take pictures are for sure speaking the
folders Oh
the science behind the the marketing the
P 91 and who is that female voice that
Google's of all your intros lavaca okay
first off with my name not that creative
my name is Patrick maca surprisingly I
was born and guest:it 1991 that's that
story it's really the the intro is a
long kept secret of the show I kind of
like the fact that no one really knows
there's a few people who like
but they've been instructed not to say
anything it's a it's a it's a big secret
if you like really paid attention you
and have some hints I don't have a
sister
it's it's not my mom Oh got it fair
enough I already don't have I don't know
if you do I think it's it's uh it's a
secret and I kind of want to keep it
that way no prod its kind of adds to the
intrigue in the mystery we always lack a
little bit unlucky with the intrigue of
business maybe one day after an anaconda
leak we'll have a leak about the intro
girl alright last question the question
I ask every guest in the realm
I need more markers top five video games
or franchises of all time
Oh in in order know whatever had the
most impact to you as a gamer I will
start off with the boring choices tetris
tetris is Doha I have played hundreds of
hours of Tetris
mmm I arranged the blocks then I go to
sleep in a dream of the blocks falling
Tetris Tetris like got me
I wouldn't say got me into gaming but I
remember distinctly like getting a
gameboy and the only game I had was
Tetris and it was like the best thing
ever
mmm getting it back to the Gameboy days
the Pokemon series on Gameboy like
pokemon red the early ones pokemon
yellow pokemon ruby and silver and gold
happy hundreds of hours of each of those
games okay on three mobile halo 3 or if
it's a serious halo 2 halo 1 got me
addicted to halo halo 2 got me a little
more and then halo 3 took over my life
for like four four years so halo three
is definitely up there yeah so we got
tetris pokemon halo 2 more mmm it's a
good question I don't know just for you
they had the most impact I'm gonna look
back on this moment be like how did you
not say to me
when you come back I if you come back I
will definitely remember this list and I
Redemption okay it's a chance to revise
but probably the trial series so I don't
know if you guys are familiar with the
motorcycle hundreds of hours of that I
put too much time into that game for
most people to consider like me to be
sane I go for golds and Platinum's on
every track I do all the experts all the
achievements every time they come out
it's crazy addiction of mind and
actually one of the games I'm really
looking forward to in February is trials
rising here uh yeah it's not launching
at a great time it has a lot of
competition to say the least so it'll be
interesting but I'm hoping all the best
for it they they seem to have done a
really good job with this last one and
then I don't know I might just go with
like a classic like Grand Theft Auto
like it's Liberty City vice city stories
four and five I mean they're all great
games and and they all do so much so
many unique things and it's hard not to
give like Rockstar some credit for what
they've done over the years you know I
like to say Michelle Obama he's got one
of the most unique yes I think I
normally people fall not saying there's
anything wrong with it but most people
fall into the Zelda the Mario's that
kind of do I never grew up playing those
I mean Super Mario 64 was like a huge
game for me but I don't know it's it's
not a game when I think about like my
moments of my life or like you know what
really got me I just never my brain
never goes to Mario for some reason yeah
I think your first also to put GTA which
is dope
it was unconventional drew by me had
conventional systems but you know the
the spots that he was playing and the
stuff that he was doing was is very
unique so his list should be unique it's
like the best unique list that
absolutely absolutely went all right man
great list so we gonna get into the poll
results so last week's poll was also I
mean who have spoken to the question
when compiling all the latest rumors
regarding Microsoft's next-generation
approach with the xbox scarlet family of
consoles do you think this multi-faceted
strategy will be too confusing to the
cat
gamer the winner at 64% of the vote was
that no the Xbox when X and s proved
that gamers understand difference huge
rope coming in at second place at 18%
was the yes 2013 all over again
Microsoft has not learned their lesson
with messaging group tied for second
place at 80% was divided ekkada don't
what good if they participated in last
week solve it
think about this I mean it's listen they
have to have to have to absolutely have
to make sure this messaging is crystal
clear because some idiot at Gamestop or
some idiot at Best Buy is not gonna know
what to tell and I'm not saying all
employees are idiots but there are some
who is not gonna know how to convey this
to the average consumer somebody's gonna
go out there and purchase something they
were not mean again it's just one of
those things where the messaging has to
be crystal clear and if you're aiming to
release multiple SKUs at the same time
that you mean that's just that's a
tricky line to walk so I hope they can
but it's not an unwarranted reason to be
a little nervous
Lord baka what do you feel about the
whole messaging app yep
I'll be the first one to say that
messaging is Microsoft's downside they
almost they very rarely do they do it
like a hundred percent usually they're
around the 80 percent mark I would say
unlike hitting their messaging and
that's you know it's a small stuff like
people not understanding exactly what
keyboard
support means on Xbox with mouse and
keyboard guys I'm I'm gonna quit Xbox
and yeah it's just like sometimes they
get caught up in their own little like
bubble and their own little atmosphere
to the point where they think people
already have assumptions about something
and then they just kind of explain to
people what they're doing from that
assumption well we assume that you know
that we're gonna keep it fair here's how
most in keyboard sports gonna work
they've they've had a kind of a small
problem with that for a while it's
definitely one of their not their strong
suits they do need a console in 2020 no
doubt and they're gonna need to
differentiate that console no doubt it's
gonna be the Xbox one x2 or whatever
they call it and yeah so they're gonna
have to get the messaging right which is
something they'll need to really focus
on because they don't historically do it
very well
um which it's very important it's very
key yeah based on what we've heard you
know we talking about different SKUs you
talked about Scarlett you talking about
Lockhart you talk about anaconda you
know possibly despite this list X boxes
and stuff like that so the messaging has
to be clear so people understand cuz we
we do remember what happened in 2013
with the whole use game situation and
you know people didn't really understand
stuff so they didn't do a good job with
like the X generally speaking and I
think more people understand how what
the X how the X is different from the s
and benefits and the non benefits and
even if it's something as simple as hey
if you have a 4k TV and get X like it's
it has to be somewhat simple the problem
will be like when they have an S an X
and an S 2 and an X 2 and a diskless
pilot it'll be like it will be as simple
as the exosphere people who play in 4k
the PAX 2 is for people who want the
premium experience the S is for the
budget gamer Charlotte for those who
have a high-speed internet connection
but also don't want to pay a lot of
money like it that's the it's gonna be
the hard part is kind of categorizing
like yep like sexualizing people to have
people know which one is made for them
you know
absolutely it'll be it'll be interesting
nonetheless hopefully they do a good job
no doubt no doubt so we gonna get into
these times actually we have a new poll
coconut at the end so stay tuned for
that we're gonna get into the star incog
you forgot something oh my bad you're
right I did forgot colleges Lords of the
iron bake I apologise Lord solve the
floor is yours thank you very much
what's up guys it's patreon time as you
may recall the beginning of December I
had that we were gonna make some changes
to the patreon um and you guys know how
we are like we like to be upfront about
everything everything so I don't want to
make any sort of changes and then people
sort of be surprised by it so just let
me talk quickly about what some of the
changes that are coming to the patreon
are the first thing is that we are going
to be eliminating the bimonthly game
giveaway and reason for this and like I
said we like we love to be afraid is
that it came to the point where there
was a lot more going out being honest um
so we had to make some adjustments there
but have no fear we're still gonna
continue to do game giveaways throughout
the year through gleam and we're looking
into other partnerships a game giveaway
so that will still be there and one left
or not Kingdom Hearts giveaway so get in
there y'all get in there y'all get in
there the stuff that's remaining with a
ten dollar giveaway between I'll
giveaway and of course a teespring
giveaway is still all in effect um
beyond that there's gonna be some
movement in terms of things that are
offered
per tier so basically when we put in all
this stuff for you guys to force us to
play certain things and do certain
things
it didn't really move the way we wanted
it to like we want you guys to force us
to do this they wanted it so bad I'm so
happy and preciate it that you guys out
there did not want that as well so that
actually those two tiers are probably
gonna get removed because again King is
in the clear he lasted like a year with
that and no
got him so but in terms of the tears
that we put down about playing online
and stuff like that playing playing
co-op stuff addict as east yet to play
dream data yet so you guys got a pris
nose buttons come on now we're gonna do
is gonna bring those things down some
tears so that you know anybody really
like anybody who supports us Atta add a
tool you're a $5 here to get enough we
got a world in a chat I believe that is
the iconic Lord Mike Mike Ibarra who's
worth oh thank you Mike
quick himself hey Mike so yes we're
gonna bring some of those things down so
you guys can have some fun please please
for us to do these things we want you to
do this all right so that that's what's
coming down the pipeline um so with that
said let's get into our thank yous yes
please and our giveaways so let's start
out with Lord Xavier Medina a new it's
non-subscriber thank you so much
learning Xavier for the support by Lord
Corey lydic Lord whisky himself
interesting III story behind that I can
assume I can assume followed by the
PlayStation brah
thank you my brother
and then we have Lord Kareem H thank you
for not slow-mo back snap I love his
icon it is the best in our escort he
renamed it Lord slow-mo of the slap then
we have Lord Kris Williams aka fastback
67 68 I believe is in the check they
think
my man is always followed by Lord Ahmed
Hernandez thank you so much for the
support and of course the Lord of X
cloud himself bill still well thank you
oh he only he's a good guy he is an
absolute hilarious follow on Twitter
yeah o team and now load a hopefully
Project X cloud please follow this guy
he's a great guy so far and I can't wait
to see these guys again at e3 could do
it and we have Lord to is Ricky Moore
thank you so much for the support my
friend sir by our patreon subscribers in
our chat always first
always always yes my lord
Sammy Prescott I believe also a fairly
new patreon subscribers will thank you
thank you so much for everything
brethren to the round Lord J Fonzarelli
and followed by the king of the stream
team Lord snailed oh yes the PD yes our
guys team lead next up is brethren from
the cradle to the grave Lord loaded
pixels and of course the man with every
aisle P color wave ever invented Lord
cat daddy fat stacks hae Lord sovereign
second identity but absolutely not least
Lord death singer oh oh right
do we have a virtual Lord of legality in
the round fool I don't know is it using
this microphone good Rick hold the whole
globe we all right on time man I was
gonna just finish it up some patreon
duties we get right into this topic into
our giveaway Chris Williams all right
the winner of our $20 gift card giveaway
is Lord cat daddy all right and last but
not least the winner of our teespring
giveaway and just to reiterate guys
auntie spring I believe don't quote me
on this after I'm little lost here I
think it's $25 or $35 max something like
that oh but you don't necessarily have
to get a t-shirt anything auntie spring
the only thing that Crawley is omitted
from this is a hoodie I believe but
everything
all righty spring giveaway to January
2019 is king of the stream team Lord
smelled oh thank you for all the support
as I said those changes will be
forthcoming little by little they'll be
trickling down I've got to change a lot
of language on stuff and and stuff like
that but if they're definitely
forthcoming so again thank you so much
for everything you guys do for us a week
over week month over month which greatly
appreciated the Lord King I got a pouch
no no I know I know you're gonna do it
thank you sir we have we have hold in
the building and um I definitely wanted
to address this so obviously we know the
biggest news right now the hottest topic
that Lord King picked these Bunji
leaving Activision and pretty much it
was said a cataclysmic effect it was a
Megaton this week everyone was going
crazy and my man
Lord hole of put out one of the best
please subscribe to this man channels
ahold law you put out virtual legality
number 13 lucky number 13 lucky number
13 right on time man
and you really broke down the legal
aspects so let's let's get into that
aspect I want to talk Lord hog about you
know basically the structure of this
terminated / amended deal and as far as
bungees lawyers being able to retain
ownership of the destiny IP which a lot
of people are surprised about as well as
activision kind of you know they're
being allowed that clean break between
both parties so uh let's talk about this
whole just the event itself what was
your initial reaction and then you know
the legal aspect if you can't sure well
I mean I think and I do apologize for my
voice I think Lord Cognito knows that
I've been getting over a little bit of
something over the last couple days as
you have to put up with little gruffness
from from me but I
think I think a lot of us knew that
there was some friction and some
relationship issues perhaps between
Activision and Bungie which is very
normal in entities this isn't describing
any kind of negative ill-will or malice
towards any particular party it's often
the case when you've got two giant
entities that operate differently and do
different things that there's sometimes
some some friction there so I don't
think it was anybody's surprised to find
out maybe they were gonna separate maybe
they're gonna go their separate ways I
think certainly the way it was presented
was like a lightning bolt to me I wasn't
aware of something happening you know in
January of 2019 or anything like that I
would have anticipated it being a little
bit closer to the release of any given
product so maybe immediately after
forsaken or something like that which in
the land of corporate bureaucracies
maybe is January after a September
release but so it came as a surprise to
me but as you said in the video that I
did which I put together last week I did
take a deeper dive into that 2010
contract that started the whole ball
rolling yes and that's a really fun
thing to do for folks that are outside
of that particular relationship because
we don't often get to see that we don't
often get to see those mega deals
between the sides because they're really
good about non-disclosure they're really
good about keeping the cards professed
and you know thankfully Activision got
into a little bit of a brouhaha
with the folks from X Infinity Ward and
so we got to see a little bit behind the
curtain and so looking at that contract
which is what I do in that video which
is if you like to hear about legal
provisions for 45 minutes but by all
means go right ahead
but it's it's a very interesting thing
so circa 2010 you've got a Bungie coming
off of major major successes with the
Halo franchise that is clearly the cat's
pajamas and the bee's knees and his
leverage leverage the greatness that is
their design philosophy against these
publisher contracts even with a company
as big as Activision where I look at
that and say their lawyers did an
absolutely fantastic job you go through
every provision of that Bungie contract
and it says Activision will pay the
bills and we keep everything when
they're done paying and do you think
that the way that they contract was
structured was because of that break
with Microsoft and they learned a thing
or two going into it and they went in
with the eyes completely open going into
it because that's gonna segue into my
other part later I think actually
separate I think Bungie in 2010 much
like Bungie right now in 2019 is it
sorry it is looking at a world in which
they don't want to be owned they don't
want their IP to be lost they don't want
to be in a situation where what happened
with Microsoft it happens again so they
lose halo over to Microsoft that was
their baby for a long time ultimately
that's okay with them because they're
they're cuttin breaks they want to make
destiny so when they're talking amongst
themselves and their internal executive
boardrooms they're saying alright we
need somebody to publish this we need to
invent a lot of Technology we need a lot
of background support for this thing we
need somebody with a big sack of cash
but we're not willing to lose the thing
probably they're talking to their
internal counsel they're talking to
their outside counsel in 2009/2010 and
probably mission number one is we're not
going to lose this the way we lost halo
and that's very clearly documented in
the way the intellectual property
ownership provisions of that contract
run which is yeah you'll pay the bills
you'll get the right to publish this
thing you'll get the right to sell this
thing you'll get the right to some
ancillary materials when we talk about
what we're making and this is some of
the language that's really interesting
and impressive is you don't we're the
final arbiters about what we're making
we control the development we control
the lore we control what this thing is I
really I really like that reference how
you used arbiter when yeah you know
bungees been around long enough that
they've probably used all major legal
terms somewhere understand no I talked
about they want to run a race and they
know they're running a marathon
it's not some myth what they're getting
accomplished you know I can do this all
day but I don't know how to work on
Ian's work on it but yeah I think they
took the contract they the the leverage
that they had which is everybody wants
to work with bunging they said hey
Activision take it or leave it we want
your sack of cash but we don't want you
to have anything at the end of the day
Activision said hey this is a business
we want to be in and if you go through
the provisions of that contract the main
thing they wanted to protect against was
main Bungie personnel leaving before the
second destiny was out hmm and and folks
leaving before essentially they made
operating revenue of I think it's 350
million and so they covered themselves
there but outside of that you saw that
after what they call in that contract
comment number two what we would
recognize as Forsaken was released right
Activision had the unilateral right to
terminate the agreement which doesn't
tell you what happened this January
because Activision was very unlikely to
pull that trigger on their own right but
it does tell you that the parties when
they were discussing this at the
beginning and when they would have been
thinking about it now had this notion in
the back of their heads that after
comment to that was an exit ramp but we
had already thought about hey yeah we've
got these four games and for comments
built in but after comment 2 we know
that Activision can just terminate this
thing and so if we Bungie decide hey
we're gonna make trouble we're gonna
indicate we don't want to continue this
relationship we're gonna do a bunch of
other stuff that are within our rights
to kind of make things known I'm gonna
get out right we can do that in the back
of it in because they have that bullet
in chamber to terminate this agreement
and that we can have that discussion at
this point in time which is what I think
happened right now gotcha I want to
focus specifically on that aspect
especially section 17.1 of the contract
oh cool rap I don't have it open I got
you covered so here's the thing like
moving forward with d3 right in possibly
you know 20 20 21 and based on the legal
fulfillment of d1 and d2 because
basically when the wait was 6 by the way
you perfectly explained it in your video
was that they had an oblong he had an
obligation of for destiny games right
and my understanding for
comet which would be I guess the dlcs
would be the equivalent of the big
expansions the taking and forsake it's
right so as we currently stand we have D
1 and D 2 that obligation completed
comet 1 aka taking king comet - aka
Forsaken completed so we know that there
were some protections in place by
activision now my question to you oak is
like do you think moving forward like
Bungie now that their separation is
there do they have like almost like a
dark period of not being able to release
something immediately that's completely
separate from that initial you know
annual pass that's remaining so to speak
you know I mean like do they do they
have to stick to that guideline in
respect to activision or from this point
on can they say hey you know super
destiny you know three point whatever
like can that happen like very soon sure
so when you're looking at contracts what
you're establish against the landscape
the geography of what you can go forward
with so what you have in that contract
is a provision like that that talks
about a two-year dark period it talks
about when the development term is over
Bungie can't make anything for two years
and Activision retains the right to
publish what they've already got for two
years so that's the landscape of what
they're looking at when they decide this
relationship wants to end Bungie
probably doesn't want that and
everything that we have seen in the
press releases that they've put out so
far doesn't indicate to me that there's
likely to be that dark period and it
doesn't really help Activision to look
like a bully on this and so what you
probably had happen behind the scenes is
Activision says okay if we just
terminate this this is what happens and
Bungie says we don't want that and then
so Activision can say okay great
and how are you gonna make us whole for
giving you something better than you
would have already had that's the
landscape of things
okay so Bungie can say okay we're gonna
do X Y or Z we're gonna cross market
with you we're gonna give you a certain
sack of money ourselves there any number
of things that can happen behind the
scenes the contract is just setting the
parameters for what would happen if none
of that occurred doc yeah I think it's
useful information I think it's it's
important knowledge to know that
Activision would have had the leverage
in those discussions but it doesn't
really help anybody for that dark period
and certainly the the I don't know if
you guys
the 8k which is the form that a public
company files to say something has
happened that they need to disclose to
their investors when they I'll that they
said that they don't anticipate making
any further material revenue on the
Destiny universe in 2019 or on so it
looks like more rights exchanged hands
than would have just been required under
the kind of purely neutral termination
under the agreement so I think there's
gonna be a dark period in terms of the
next major destiny released by virtue of
the fact that it's it's not done it's
not developed yet but outside of that I
don't think there's an artificial
constraint on that my best guess is that
Bungie rightly thinks that they don't
want to have this kind of numerical
release schedule where you have to
access all the loot and you have to get
rid of the previous four planets and
they're gonna try to build something a
little bit more Universal and more
framing okay I got one more question
before I open it up to mock and everyone
else sure want to talk about the Sony
exclusivity structure and as we know you
know the the expansions and certain
aspects that come out with the game you
know the PlayStation has had exclusive
content maps and so on and so forth yeah
for my understanding again correct me if
I'm wrong Lord Howe is that that was
part of the Activision agreement so if
in theory this is now broken are there
is Bungie free to dissolve that well
like how does that work that's my
question yeah so what happens in 2010
and what's been going on since then is
that when you make an intellectual
property you get out you get a bundle of
rights that's what we call it in law
school and that's the right to make
derivative works that's the right to
sell it on your own that's the right to
do a bunch of other stuff what they said
is all right we've got this bundle of
rights in destiny as we know it and
we're gonna hand off certain rights to
you Activision in exchange for large
amounts of money and those rights where
you get to publish it you get to market
it you get to sell it and you get to
distribute it and so Activision says
thank you for those rights we're gonna
use those we're gonna enter into an
agreement with Sony to Sony's gonna give
us a bundle of money in order to give
them exclusivity on these things that's
a contract that exists mm-hmm to the
extent it exists right now that
maintains its existence despite the fact
that they're ending their own
contractual relationship
now there could be provisions in those
contracts that say hey if you lose the
rights X Y or Z then we lose the rights
and things like that but Sony probably
would have been at the table having
confidential discussions to make sure
that what they paid for they get and
nobody is it there is not a single party
involved in this matter that is
interested in burning Sony's bridges
right now whatever they paid for okay
that not when you say keep whatever they
pay for through the duration of the
Destiny franchise or do the duration of
Destiny - as an entity so we don't have
eyes on these contracts but it would be
silly for me if I were the lawyer for
Bungie or if I were the lawyer for
Activision to have negotiated anything
more than kind of a property by property
license because that's how you're gonna
maximize your dollars mmm so my guess is
that this applies to Forsaken and then
it's all hands on deck for whoever wants
to pay got you okay that great answer
thank you so much let's open it up but
Lord maka man let's talk about this
thing I don't see the new work and you
know what was this talk about the
emotional answer like what did you feel
when you first heard this news and you
know just in general what's your
thoughts so no surprise probably to
everyone but Angie is one of my favorite
Studios ever and they've made some of my
favorite games of all time and for what
all the deaths all the all the crap
destiny gets it has a best shooting game
like gunplay out of any game girl ever
next I will argue that to the death I
can't personally with better gun at talk
time you saying it's the best game ever
made it's that like one play is the best
in the genre yep appreciate it for that
and a Bungie does great work they don't
always hit the mark with everything like
for example armor lock and Halo Reach am
i right said have a lot of respect for
that studio I got I got to visit it and
I met a lot of great people who work
there and I have nothing but love for
Bungie at the same time everyone seems
to be thinking this is like a Power Move
by Bungie and Bungie is happy and it's
pretty happy too I don't know yeah I
don't think destiny is the financial
success they want but she talks went
down way before or sorry Activision Sox
well wait
before they reported dis news first and
it didn't sell as well as they wanted it
to and Activision was spending a lot of
money to keep what they probably felt
like was destiny afloat even though they
didn't feel like it was necessarily
coming back and and you know it wasn't
worth it to them like I'm not surprised
at the same time I do think that like
both of the parties are benefitting
pretty well from it and I don't it's
just like a Bungie wins or Activision
wins probably good for both of them in
the long term and I'm really excited to
like see what Bungie can do with destiny
now that they don't have Activision
telling them to you know make the Jade
rabbit PlayStation exclusive and you
know smaller things like that like the
lever verse and it'll be interesting for
them to just see what they come up with
when they're able to decide how hardcore
they want their game to be what they
want their community to play how they
want their community to engage without a
extra voice unfortunately I think it's
gonna take as long a long time to see
any fruits of this flavor
I think everyone kind of wants to see oh
we want to see destiny 3 released
tomorrow it'll be a while before we see
anything but I think it's a good move
for both companies long term and
hopefully for the gamers it's also you
know great hopefully destiny is a
fantastic game moving forward yeah fair
enough fair enough lore so I want to
just get cheer from the emotional aspect
oh you know obviously you are not the
destiny head that we are but how did you
feel like you know when you heard the
news break I felt I was happy for Bungie
because I think this move puts them in
position where they start to resemble
the bunch of old where they you know
their true vision for this game comes
out that said I don't give a rat's ass
about destiny and what it is on that is
not that that's not the Bungie game that
I want but I I agree with uh with maka
said it what this allows them to do
moving forward with destiny 3 at some
point is that it becomes more of what
they had planned for destiny initially
where which is going to be this living
game that they continue to iterate upon
and not necessarily so I don't know that
we'll see after destiny 3 maybe we don't
see a numbered destiny for quite some
time now and everything's gonna build
off of the backbone and whatever that
game is so I'm excited for that in that
regard
another thing is we have to think about
how this sort of separation affects what
they're doing with Nettie's and on that
ease gave them 100 million the moment
properties and obviously bun is a very
big company they're not I mean they can
have multiple teams working on certain
things but um it's gonna be interesting
to see you know what they give priority
to moving forward within the next six
months to a year wouldn't see more of no
but I'm excited for them I really am
because I don't think I don't think they
should get a people talk about Microsoft
and I'm getting back together I can see
maybe sometime in the future maybe them
working on something exclusive together
but I like bungee being by itself um
interesting
I like that also really quick to go on
someone's uh comment in the chat you
guys asked earlier about my favorite
game franchises this kind of ties in it
to Activision as well actually needs to
focus on a Tony Hawk game I've got a
Tony Hawk is franchise that got milk to
the bone it requires some love and care
though though no fit read up not King I
need your feedback here before I bring
it back to Hulk Oh Oh should do aspect
like what did you feel when you heard
this dude alright so um I was in chat
with floored attic at the time when it
uh transpired and my phone just started
going nuts like Twitter my phone just
started going nuts my Twitter box was
insane um is it me or do you look at
videogame partnerships as relationships
and um in in in this whole thing I
always viewed Bungie and Microsoft as
two people that you know you know got
together and it was beneficial in any
way as they peak you know Bungie came
with Halo and it helped establish
Microsoft as a gaming entity
and also solidified Bungie as a
first-person shooter on console like it
can be done so both of these guys were
riding at their peak and the separation
of the two relationship you know you
know for this guy so you know it was a
good game but really and then you know
went on to do destiny in the new
relationship
oh my god no
- super check out the mods gaming Tudela
super chat thank you brother he said
sounds like Bungie was the masters of
their destiny a shout out to Lord Bowl
slave off GP with the file super chat
thank you so much appreciate it continue
Lord King with the relationship your
breakdown when I saw Phil has massively
changed a lot of people views on things
because he was the first one to slide up
like like he knew a son but hey
you know I'm just letting you know we do
appreciate you yeah go I don't believe a
bungee you know be becomes reacquired by
Microsoft for anything like that I'm not
no disillusions of those type of things
but I also understand as a head of a
company that was very bold that was very
very poignant and people look to that
tweet and retweet it endings
you know speculations all over the place
just feel just just let you know like yo
we here we willing to work with you
whatever happened over there that was
over there and we don't get past that
boo
but hey I was so happy they walked away
with this stuff right and because we all
felt that Activision was the evil minds
behind this thing and they're left to
their own devices that Bungie will
become great again right I believe he
had a fault in anything that went wrong
with destiny as well as Activision
pushing to get it to turn into that
fortnight cheddar right right and I
think because it wasn't generating cash
like a fortnight or any type of super
extravaganza type of game like the Red
Dead or whatever they felt that it
wasn't a success where in any generation
games of that revenue are success so I
just feel that they're in a good space I
think Activision walks out of it in a
good space they don't got to keep those
servers up and all that other stuff oh
and they can move on and let's see
what's gonna happen next
um I don't think that Bungie comes
Microsoft exclusive and too much so many
money out there let's just see what
happens
gonna bring it back to our Lord hole get
a minute as far as the we talked about
that now talk about the story
exclusively we all I also want to ask
you over what about
the the the blizzard aspect the
battlenet aspect you know obviously we
know that you know happened on PC and
that's under that Activision umbrella as
well as the Vicarious Visions and high
Moon Studios you know that they were
brought in by Activision to assist
Bungie so um what do you feel happens
now as far as that relationship does
that just immediately dissolve I mean we
know Blizzard made the statement that
you know operations will continue on
battlenet as is but like what what do
you foresee with that Lord Hawk in
reference to it yeah I suspect that as
part of their separation agreement they
talked about how long the essentially
the backend maintenance will be
maintained by Activision and so that's
on battlenet I mean the one thing I
would add to the other pieces of
conversation that I've heard I'm a
corporate lawyer right so I'm already
half evil by DNA what I look at the
acquisition relationship is both the
good and bad I I agree that I think that
Activision had its own notions of what
the return on investment should be for a
game of this type I agree that I think
it was probably Activision sitting on
Bungie shoulder that took them in a
direction for the initial release of
Destiny 2 that was probably not the best
for overall long-term profitability of
whatever this destiny thing is but on
the other hand I see things like star
citizen and other kick-started non
quote-unquote published games lost in
the weeds without somebody in the back
saying hey you need to deliver a product
hey you need to scope hey you need to
focus on these things and Bungie hasn't
lived entirely on its own in a long long
long long time and so I do wonder
whether they want to just be completely
free right the second or whether they
are going to be looking for somebody to
you know a minimal kind of related with
somebody with a large sack of money that
may not be trying to change the entire
digital storefront infrastructure and
community at the same time
[Laughter]
company so I really do think I think
battle that's gonna stick around I think
that at bare minimum Bungie is
ultimately going to have a relationship
with somebody for distribution
maybe not publishing but some storefront
certainly on beast and along with that
might come certain about some money
certain exclusivity
I don't think they're gonna be bought by
anybody anytime soon so what you're
saying is that scene III is exclusive to
the epic store anything crazy short of a
Martian colony you're betting the wrong
way right this second oh this is great
we got Lord bloody knuckles in the brow
it he's a passionate forest I'll call
you a former destiny I mean that would
be the biggest because the fact that as
you put it in the past I was like I'm
the most passionate yes he's one of the
most passionate most chomping at the bit
he said long ago just get me in here for
this quick segment real quick and I have
to get your take real quick as we got a
lot to discuss as a big show but okay
what's your take on this whole situation
all right so my quick taking before
start that I want to say a mocker it's
great to see you on here I'm glad to see
you in hope I'm hearing your lawyer take
because as I said your evil by Nature I
love that because it because it helps to
explain a lot of what I'm gonna break
down what you have already brought up so
one of the things in this it comes from
a lot of the talking especially Jason
Schreyer who's done a lot of things we
saw what already was coming out from the
troubles that destiny has been having
from Bungie doing a lot of the the
making from the very first time around
and what they were experiencing with
destiny too we saw activist bloody come
back come back we have a problem
[Laughter]
the only thing either thing I would add
now I think I've talked to you about
this Lord kognito I don't know that I
have with anybody else but my you know
my brother works at high Moon yes and so
you know I can't I I don't have any
specific information on anything so
there's nothing for me to disclose but I
do think Activision is now in a place
where they're gonna have a lot of their
eggs in one very large Call of Duty
shaped basket and certainly the support
studio structure that they've put
together or mostly destiny and Call of
Duty is probably going to be re-examined
it's no coincidence that this all
happened in the shadow of what amounts
to five separate executive changes at
the Activision level so that's something
to pay attention to as well know that
yeah sorry about that my owner Jeff for
a second but the thing was that we've
seen how how how this goes in and who
can definitely can't agree on that or
our state because he knows how the
legality and contracts work and I know I
have a couple lawyers in my family so
you know there's always multiple
contracts that go out especially when
you're you going through multiple
corporations and stuff like that and and
try not to put everything under one
single contract unless they can
absolutely lock it down
with no sort of loss to any one entity
at this point so with Activision and
Bungie splitting it's a good thing and a
bad thing and the good thing for is that
one they're gonna continue maintaining
the servers because that's that was one
of their biggest holding points for for
Bungie was that even at the split
Activision still has to maintain the
servers and everything that that's gonna
use to be able to keep that going to
support the player base both from the
console side and all their players as
well as what they have set with Blizz
acti with supporting the people on
battlenet so that it's not going to
affect the PC players too much on that
end and the good thing is that Bungie
did have the habit be able to keep the
IP rights and the publishing rights and
every
on Ford now the biggest thing is how
it's going to affect the PC players
going forward because remember PC
players did not get destiny once so they
were already going in half-cocked with
missing a lot of what set the foundation
for going into - destiny - and then
destiny to being an exclusive to the
battlenet because Activision were
thinking at the time of launching it
that they were going to be able to keep
that under their umbrella and be able to
keep using it as a big moneymaker
because they started to see what it can
kind of bring in now we've also seen
with the struggles that Bungie has
suffered with destiny - because it
remember in the beginning with the
weather right after the launch they were
having troubles with war my curse for
Cyrus and keeping up with the mmm-hmm
basic content structure and stuff like
that on senton cosmetics and all that
stuff really pushed into the ever verse
store now everyone was blaming
Activision that wasn't entirely an
Activision decision Activision was
supporting it but it was Bungie who were
coming with them at that aspect now
the other biggest thing is that you
mentioned the two studios with Vicarious
Visions and hi moon and them being a
part of the activision that is going to
be the biggest hindrance to Bungie
because the fact that remember Bungie is
a studio that has what four hundred
three hundred some-odd employees working
on this and yet that's their main team
who's what writing the main story and
doing all the bigger base games because
they did you know destined one in the
destiny - at launch then they had their
they took a small portion of that team
that was working as the live team to
continue any added content well the next
team started producing and everything
that's coming next they were having so
many issues with keeping up the content
that's why Activision gave them those
two other studios to help support the
live team with everything that's coming
out that's why they had vicarious in
high Moon they were the ones who are
doing everything alongside the live the
the small sect of Bungie that was the
live team and here's the biggest thing
that really shows that they were having
troubles with it especially after the
launch of forsaken we saw what they had
envisioned from the original
storywriter that don't forget that they
fired before destiny one use a majority
of his storyline and just slightly
altered it for the Forsaken because
remember this time around they did Jen
or The Crow the big villain but also a
big help because the fact that was his
original place in the original story
yeah yeah yeah so now we're seeing that
they really have written themselves in a
corner that they had to go back and
reuse all that script that they fired
the writer for back then and recycle it
now because the fact that they've been
in such a spot that they aren't being
able to keep up with the story that they
wanted to write so although there's a
lot of back and forth with this and the
only thing that's keeping them afloat
right now especially was that money from
Nettie's with getting that hundred
million dollar and a lot of people
thought it was it will it definitely
will for a while but we have to see how
they're gonna implement it because a lot
of people thought it was them buying
sock no it was a donation and an
investment into Bungie that gave them a
guaranteed they gave one of their
executives a guaranteed seat on the
board of directors with Bungie and it
would be utilized in any form that
Bungie saw fit to maintain an either
current or future projects that's the
biggest thing so they can use a portion
of that to keep sustaining destiny and
paying their employees and whatever else
they need to whether that goes into help
pushing for for marketing and anything
that they do itself and they don't sign
any contracts with anyone else as well
as um anything else that they're gonna
need to do to help keep those finances
and profits coming in no fair enough
fair enough I want to get hold on one
aspect that you said bloody and this is
your to the the net ease and first of
all before we too bad that's two parts
here net one is Nettie's and then the
the second part I want to shout out to
l-boogie in the super chat thank you for
the talents of it he said don't forget
that fraud lawsuit so I'll put that in
our chat I don't know if Hogue if you
saw that also sent that you do directly
I know if you get a chance to say that
as well because apparently I don't know
how legitimate this is right is that
apparently Activision is supposedly
currently under investigation for fraud
follow
Bunji split so I don't know if Hogue if
you've even heard this news I just sent
you a piece I don't know if you got a
chance to look at it I mean Larry said
minutes ago yesterday is that they were
that they were getting of marketing
fraud lawsuits
so I guess activational the two parts
101 part hold about the you know that
the Nettie's thing and then in reference
to that and then second about this
potential investigation sure sure I got
to work and I'm sorry all right as a
matter of fact you'll probably see my
name in a couple of articles tomorrow on
the security virtually galley for tea
you know I actually have to practice law
occasionally and not just do you know
we'll see yeah so you know as far as I
know as far as I understand it was a
fairly standard working capital
investment where they give you a big
sack of money and they take a certain
amount of equity and they they ask for
certain control rights and and I think
that as far as I know and I haven't dove
into this with any particular
specificity of late it doesn't have any
kind of bells or whistles or control
provisions that you wouldn't expect in
that kind of relationship so I think
everybody assumes Bungie is going to
build some kind of mobile Korea and
something but nobody really knows for
sure and I certainly don't have any
confidential information on that
I'm the fraud stuff if unless it's
something different than what I've
already been working on today what I
have seen so far is a couple of
plaintiffs firms start putting together
notions of a potential class-action
lawsuit on a securities fraud claim and
I'll say a couple things here you're
gonna get the the first bits of these
exclusive mode hold ability it is yeah
so I would ask tabat this from by a
couple of reporters this morning and one
of the things is that all of you should
know is that this is pretty standard
operating procedure now I would say
unfortunately but it really depends on
how you feel about securities law
implementation in general essentially
every time a bad something happens
to accompany a plaintiff's law firm
starts putting together a class that
could be a security breach that can be
you know the loss of credit card
information that can be an environmental
spill that can be kind of standard
things that might otherwise have been
disclosed against if something bad
happens and there's a you know kind of
cataclysmic looking rollercoaster hill
of a of a stock price for a day or two
then these people put together these
notions on the basis of there's a rule
in the Securities Act that basically
says you can't lie on the forms and you
can't mislead people on the forms you
can't only tell truths that mislead
people and you know that when when
Activision gives this information on
Bungie when they file what is it called
a form 8-k that tells the world that
Bungie is separating from activision
their stock price plummets and were they
defrauding the market because they knew
this was going to happen for a period of
time when they didn't disclose it those
are questions that might come out and
discovery they might not I none of this
really bothers me from a legal
perspective this is kind of the normal
operating procedure for a company that
experiences this whether or not they get
a plaintiff put together these are in
general weak weaker claims these are not
the kind of fraud claims you
traditionally think of as fraud oh the
guy moved a million dollars and made it
fifty thousand I don't think you think
not that are truly lies this is more
along the lines of when they filed their
quarterly report in November they've got
a line in there Activision Publishing
description that says we have a we have
a long-lived alliance with Bungie to
develop their dusty universe and that
sentence exists untouched as of November
and were the people that bought stock
between November and January were they
being deceived in some fashion is the
claim most those get kicked out because
you're not you have to fraud requires
what we call knowledge or what we really
call when we're being fancy lawyer is
see enter okay in that they have to have
the intent to deceive and so it's a hard
claim to make and what happens in these
cases is they put the class together and
then Activision would seek to have it
immediately dismissed and if that if
they do get it dismissed it's gone and
if they don't then you settle because
there's no point in going through the
whole process
of the entire class action so that'll be
the big key and that'll be four to six
months out from from here if they get a
class put together
I'll go dougie fellow taught strokes it
doesn't bother me it's not that unusual
but obviously you'd prefer not to be
looked at for a potential securities
fraud claim it's just more the optics of
it is just really bad opposed to the
circumstances being terrible yeah the
Securities Exchange Act works is you
have a private cause of action for one
of these lies and so every firm every
lawyer that specializes in these is
constantly looking at the stock market
for what exactly you saw in the
Activision and then potentially trying
to gather a class because when you've
got a securities law class action
essentially the lawyers make between 40
and 60 percent of the ultimate damages
claim this is where you're getting into
why people hate lawyers and it's this
kind of stuff gotcha
okay let me jump in May because you guys
everyone is nice ability thank you see
the law and order digit of I salute
obeys all that weight with that yeah
well I want to say something I was like
hope I'm glad that you gave that that
description that that you did because
that's some interesting stuff that not a
lot of people understand when it comes
to the the back side of lost is
especially with class actions like that
and I got to learn fancy new words see
enter yes yes sir it's like a magic word
it's like a Harry Potter word you see a
whole job in jewels in here man let me
jump in real quick so is so much to
unpack here you know over the years it's
kind of a mahkum and it's like my
unwavering love for this damn franchise
I mean despite you know the many flaws
the game has of course I have my bias
but in my opinion it's the precise
gunplay it's still a match it's the best
three to six minute cooperative
experience as far as consult as far as
in in-game activity on as far as race
don't get me started with the music but
my initial thoughts were just wow
like Bungie has some great legal
representation in my opinion in
negotiation and walk away with full
ownership of this IP I mean this is
definitely Megatron if information as
far as the deal now you know I'm again
Whitlock in the sense that from the
Activision standpoint I also I mean
don't get me wrong I'm happy that they
have their independence and we we always
want a creator to be able to do what
they envision and we know the
relationship was rocky at some point
right but we also have to be clear to
that active reading stepped away from
the stand point say hey you know what
like we don't feel this investment is
generating what we intended it to you
know so that's the key also aspect that
people not realize and then like bloody
was saying like moving forward you don't
saying like all that responsibility like
Falls now on Bungie you can sit there
and we can be mine eyes that really not
right but one thing I do net more in
English all point you know when you got
those trailers you got that information
it was on point and at the same time it
was it was done in a bigger scope and
then you had the high moons you had the
Vicarious Visions
you know all this now falls on them and
that's a big deal I don't want anyone to
kind of minimize it so we're gonna see
what happens with the future of the
franchise you don't have saying you know
also as well as this partnership with
net ease you know I'm saying you know
obviously you know some people gonna say
you know you're gonna be training in
evil publisher for an evil investor we
don't know what that aspect is you know
I don't want to I don't want to
speculate on that you know saying also
like Lord Hawk said you know as far as
the future going forward with the next
quote-unquote comet right there DLC how
does that structure going on going forth
and um you know at this point you know
multi-player or not really doesn't
what happens to me is bottom line you
know ultimately I would love to see some
type of a cross play across progression
in the future I feel the community
deserves that
you know never in a million years that I
think this would happen so that's my
thoughts on tattoo super chat before we
move on I gave it the whole um one Lord
man's he said what Studios with Twitter
what studio makes better halo though
Bungie or 343 I think we all got the
answer yeah that much and then uh Lord
kiss moving a building with a super chat
um who makes a better you better halo
three four three but again with this you
got the same thing man but uh Laura Hall
got let's you Rat Man because first of
all thank you for coming in on this or
last minute he appreciates it so super
knowledge Manning like I said you always
welcome to join the room you know with
your tremendous legal knowledge
informing gamers of what we don't know
about you have to teach me how to get a
logo up there instead of like this black
screen nobody wants to see my face right
now I'm still recovering from but
overall man just you know I'll let you
put the cap on the cherry on the sundae
with this topic you know moving forward
you know Adi how do you feel you know I
I think it's exciting I love destiny
obviously I think that mistakes were
made going from one to two I miss I miss
the old destiny one planets I am all
incorporated I I think in the in the
games as a service world that we're
moving into destiny is a perfect fit for
that but it needs to be kind of rebuilt
from the ground up so it wouldn't
surprise me if you saw essentially all
the assets that they've got for destiny
wanna destiny to in all the comments and
everything else made into a Destiny
universe type product and they do own
all the intellectual property they could
do that and they could build something
really big and with kind of the the free
to play elements and then they too could
be sued for the dances that they
incorporate that's why they're gonna get
in bed with epic is because they'll
already have all the legal defenses
ready to go
[Applause]
speaking of epic transition if guys got
to leave I understand it's cool I don't
we run a little late um you know
definitely we heard that the epic news
as far as a division tool kind of
leaving steam at the altar this is a
load addicts topic so I'll just jump off
real quick and obviously we heard this
news breakdown and um you know it looks
like they they have this defection going
on and you know they announced it you
know in favor of the epic store that
division to a huge huge get you know
Lord market Lord hold out if he's still
here if you want to talk about it but um
you know what do you guys feel about
this that you know division two how
impactful is this in news absolutely no
one people like money and yeah epic has
money and or that gives you more money
for what you sell so I'm not surprised
obviously it's a little bit of a risk
taking your game off of steam but it's a
calculated risk that I imagined they sat
down and they crunched the numbers and
it made sense they're making a lot more
money per per sale and like look it's
all IQ plays the thing really so what
does it matter like the thing about PC
gamers is they'll kind of play don't
launch their games for whatever they
need to launch them they don't think
they really care
mm interesting always have everything on
Steam on one place but like I don't
think they like no one is like you know
there's no steam the podcast where all
the gamers to only play steam game I
think as long as you have that PC and
you you you know you have the hardware
and you want to play the game you'll
figure out a way to play it absolutely I
don't know if we still all have the
incredible oh you do I don't know
whether you wanted me to pop off or not
right shred folks yeah I am however long
we could hold you but I don't you a six
I mean it's a blessing you're doing
got the football on oh um I think this
is a super important story I think you
might have seen me tweet about it but
basically I did a video about this at
the end of the year when Steam released
their top 12 their Platinum class of
video games that had released and the
thing that really jumped out at me was
that Ubisoft was the last man standing
in terms of the big publishers that were
really making headway on Steam because
you've got battlenet doing all of
Activision stuff because you got
Bethesda moving a lot of their stuff off
to theirs because you've got origin for
EA Ubisoft yeah they released their
stuff on you play but they also released
their stuff on Steam so Assassin's Creed
Odyssey and far cry 5 held two of the
spots of the top ten on Steam and so I
said you know that's what epic and steam
are really fighting over right now is
what's gonna happen to you be soft and
so when division two drop that hammer on
what turned out to be a slightly
exciting news day for the videogame
industry that was a very big deal to me
now I think they're testing the waters I
think it's nice to get 88 percent of the
money but if you're getting 88 percent
of you know a million eyeballs instead
of a hundred million that's not gonna
work but I think ubisoft's calculated
decision on this is hey we don't need a
lot of help telling people division to
exists so you're gonna go find it if
you're interested in playing it and
eighty-eight percent instead of 70
percent is a heck of a lot of money for
you to stop doing and if it does work
out how they'd like it to work out I
don't see them going back and this is
exactly the kind of thing epic needed to
really start pushing more and more
eyeballs over to their service as well
as giving away really cool free games go
get you to the finish it's awesome oh
yeah what did you feel when the news
broke
you know the whole epic store thing you
saw I think it's great I'm always up for
anybody disrupting the status quo I just
so what is what's most interesting about
this to me is that this really puts them
in a position where they really really
have to reevaluate their practices they
haven't really despite what epic has
been doing in spite what this code has
been doing they haven't necessarily
changed anything in terms of in terms of
game
and stuff like that not that much has
changed so they're sort of holding
ground and saying we're the juggernaut
we don't feel necessarily threatened yet
but that should not be the case they
really need to start reevaluating and
the same goes for discord
if discord despite you know 200 million
users on discord they don't have a huge
triple-a game on their exclusive to
their uh to the service just yet so they
need to think about that because epic is
gonna be is looking to snap up all of
these and when it comes to the ubisoft
conversation they've already said
there's gonna be more Ubisoft games on
there so I don't know how long this this
partnership goes for but you can pretty
much look at you know whatever big games
down the pipeline for Ubisoft coming on
to the epic store in the PC space so
they really need to start evaluating how
much money they gon throw out there to
get some more of these exclusives and I
it's for me
again I think competition just raises
the bar all the way around it forces you
evaluate your practices and I think only
we get we get the best out of all that
so I just want to see them start
changing this stuff up mm-hmm absolutely
Oh actually Lord Lord King not really
noticing that these dudes is creeping up
on the side and lube up little stuff is
being smashed away from from this guy
and that guy and I remember when you
know steam was the end-all be-all for PC
gamers was when it established itself in
that area right okay so you go there all
your stuff is there now you have these
up this these options is all over the
place and once one of these dudes and
whole like slepak store the reason why I
say is because that's a big thing right
once it starts clicking and everybody
starts to gravitate towards the one
thing you're gonna see the my is esteem
rapidly is just gonna drop out you know
the floor is gonna fall out from her and
me personally I hope they
can switch it around I hope they can
flip it around but epic is offering
something that a lot of dudes can't
offer like steam can't offer if you use
our engine you get this back and you put
the game on our stuff so they don't have
that option to do that and I think
you're looking at a dinosaur actually
going out the pasture mmm
it makes sense I could run back in the
day when source was a big thing the
source engine and they reached the point
where it felt like they weren't really
making games anymore they would just you
know sort of you know that bit up
picture that people paint well you know
gabe newell sitting on a pile of gold it
like looks like you know making games
and again maybe that's not necessarily
true but again it comes back to bite you
when you're not moving innovation
forward like you know there's no reason
why they shouldn't be making more games
it's no reason why the source engine
shouldn't be at the forefront of these
engines that are being utilized today
just no reason for it you've said the
source engine and i was just like what
the source is that's the dinosaur
verification yeah i like the epic story
yes I like the discord store I'm a fan
of watching I think somebody said
disruptive events i I think that for a
long time
gotten to sit on 7030 and gotten to sit
there for a while and I think they're
doing the right thing by essentially
holding back right now and saying let's
see what happens but I for one loved the
fact that epic is almost like the the
nouveau riche has come in and just
accidentally made 300 million a month
and says what are we gonna do with this
sack of money and says well instead of
hoarding it or doing something
disreputable with it let's start a game
store because we
we've looked at the numbers and we can
do it at 88 instead of 70 and come at us
valve and I think that benefits a lot of
folks the only people it really doesn't
benefit is valve yeah and and then I
don't have ownership interest in valve I
think it's a great thing for everybody
ultimately yeah there could be a period
of time where there's a lot of stuff
that is disruptive people don't like it
people are uneasy hey if I were
marketing for epic store I wouldn't
necessarily have gone the direction of
just signing exclusives my I would have
tried to pass on a portion of the 18% as
between developers and consumers because
I think if you can become the store that
is selling the steam $15 games for $13
which still gets the developer more
money I think if you become that place
then you're gonna take over the market
but outside of the fact that I don't
love exclusives I think it's great that
there are more and more entrants that
have a real viable economic model to
really create change in this environment
absolutely agree that we completely Neil
I want to go shout out actually located
mega in the soup chat thank you so I
said GOG showing love to iron Lords
thank you much appreciated definitely
hope you nailed it man I'm with you man
IIIi think just the competition is great
I like how aggressive they're being you
know they're not playing around you know
and listen like like Laura Marcus said
money talks man more money
that's what people want to hear you know
so we saw action over there I've got
that other game that's kind of like a
dead cells thing I forgot the name of it
off top but um it looks fantastic and
people are going over there so we'll see
how this plays out moving forward if
more people continue to kind of jump
ship it'll be interesting with destiny
as an ST fan and see what happens with
that
you know how aggressive you know epic
gets and then uh the way epic is moving
right now
you know coordinate some news you know
they apparently you know unity it has
some argument with some other dev and
now you know epics encouraging
developers away from unity so it's like
epics got their hand in everything right
my favorite part of that story was the
part that came out that said the Tim
Sweeney and epic had only decided to do
that that day yes that they read the
articles and that they just talked to by
insoluble and they said yeah sure let's
do this let's just let's try to destroy
unity while we rest but you gotta love
it because at the end
as a gamer competition is good for us
you know you love it until I mean let's
bowl Tirana cards used to be the
disrupter right when they started out
this was a group of developers that had
to get away from the evil publisher
because they weren't allowed to have
credits in their games etc etc everybody
was on board Electronic Arts and pinball
machine and everything else this is and
I'm really old so I apologize to your
audience but at that point they were
what epic is right this second even
though epics been in the business a lot
longer and now they're Electronic Arts
so you got you know whatever that line
is from The Dark Knight does happen to
folks right now you know he said I'm
telling you who likes to see the world
burn destruction it's a fantastic table
all right we got to go we got a flat do
because we've got maka here I know how
long we got 200k we do a quick CSCS
round up sir yeah so last week we had a
CES 2019 law and like every year
obviously all the new tech that gets an
announcement talked about and people get
excited about yeah I know we're all
excited about you know the the diaper
monitors and the thing that they had
like the flying uber car yeah you had
the working car that it looks like
claptrap from a borderline Easter yes
what I wanted to focus on was really
what the technologies that were
presented that I think are gonna inform
the console experience in the coming
generation right and I decided to focus
on three particular things a k5g
and of course graphics improvements and
Bibles Nvidia and AMD so let's start
with a que real quickly for a que all
the major manufacturers talked about a
que in some way shape or form
the thing about aka at this point right
it's still sort of a pipe dream it's not
there yet
especially for mass consumption by the
consumers but by the time we look we
look at when these consoles these new
consoles are looking to launch it sort
of makes sense because I think when you
talk about years ago when they tried to
when the entire industry tried to push
us to like 3d TVs right and in the end
it came off like it was just a gimmick
and it didn't really work and it crashed
and burned very quickly when they
started focusing on 4k that's a more
viable upgrade that everyone can see
that is it's something that that that
makes sense over the long term and it
isn't a gimmicky it doesn't require
extra peripherals anything like that so
I think a K is in that same line where
eventually 8k will be something that's
viable for the mass consumer it's not
there yet but again I think I think
entertainment and movies in particular
and and gaming all the ones that push
that that narrative forward and by 2020
2021 we start looking at these consoles
I'm not saying we'll have a cake if a
cake compatibility in these consoles
when they start but if you look at maybe
a mid gen refresh of these next-gen
consoles we could see some sort of a
case support so it's I think it's
interesting that they started talking
about that now the next thing that I saw
that's that is the most obvious one
right is all of the the graphic stuff
obviously Nvidia is pushing their
ray-tracing they're pushing their uh
their super sampling they're deep
learning super sampling and they showed
a lot of mobile processors they showed
the desktop processor the r-tx 2060 they
show mobile versions of these processors
that are super powerful that are
basically in almost all laptops that are
coming out within the next year the year
and a half so what's interesting about
that although we know NVIDIA isn't
really there aren't the ones we're going
to be making the tech for our future
consoles switch is built on Tegra mobile
sort of tech stuff like that so it for
me it's just what's interesting about
Nvidia is that they're taking a
completely different track than AMD
usually nvidia comes out they're the
first ones to come out they always
they're very expensive
but they're at the forefront of whatever
the newest tech is and usually what
happens is AMD comes up from behind they
make it cheaper more power efficient and
generally in the same performance area
as an INT as an nvidia product for a
considerably lower price what's
happening that we're seeing now is that
they're diving for the first time in a
long time they're diverging paths nvidia
is really focusing on RT x and deep
learning super sampling whereas AMD with
the with with the new risin chips
and with the radio on seven announcement
they're not focusing on that at all
they're they're all about pushing
resolution so again a que and pushing
frame rates that's what they're pushing
performance above all of this other new
stuff that nvidia is pushing and what's
most interesting about that in the
console spaces AMD is working with both
PlayStation and Xbox on these future
consoles so again I don't think we were
speculating way back do we see ray
tracing in any of that stuff in any of
our consoles moving forward I don't know
that we do see that stuff maybe within
the next eight years maybe decade
because of these partnerships with AMD
intensive song yeah so yeah so that's
pretty interesting and we saw fell
Spencer up on stage with the CEO of AMD
talking about you know that partnership
so I think it's it's it's interesting to
see because I don't think we see any of
those bells and whistles that in videos
talking about in the console space right
and then the next big thing that I saw
was 5g right obviously 5g is is is the
next step in sort of wireless
communication and they've been talking
about phones coming out this year
beginning starting this year with 5g
capabilities I don't really see us
having a big rollout of 5g until at
least next year but again Microsoft has
been talking about X cloud and and how
5g is integral to that and then we've
been seeing more and more companies
obviously I've 5g in terms of the the
phone in mobile space the big guns there
are coming out with 5g phones and
starting to talk about their 5g networks
and how they planned
implement this stuff and then on the
gaming side we're seeing Google jumping
in we're saying Mazon jumping in
obviously Microsoft
Exploud Verizon jumping in IG is the
backbone to all of this and again I just
think the industry has shown us that
they're all moving in that same
direction so this isn't a pipe dream
editing this isn't Microsoft talking
about pie in the sky this is real this
is coming and everybody's on board
pretty much so what do you guys think
about this am I wrong am i am I am i
reaching what do you guys think maka
maka me jump off what do you think about
a list oh boy all right so let's start
off this part with you can direct your
angry tweets at me over I'm going to say
something controversial and I'm probably
gonna offend a lot of people I've had
this position for a very long time I
think resolution in gaming is wildly
overrated and I think people put way too
much time and effort into 4k 4k 4k and
counting the pixels on their monitor in
my opinion uh 4k gaming doesn't always
make sense if I analyze a scenario and I
have a game running at 50% and that game
I have two options I can go to 4k or I
can stay at 1080p and up the shadows and
the textures and the framerate and the
performance and the particle effects and
the fire I'm choosing 1080p every single
time and I don't know I at some point we
got this the Xbox one X can do 4k and
everyone kind of grabbed on to that and
it's dope that it can do 4k a 4k TV I
understand it looks phenomenal
but I think this push to pixels is not a
good push and I think people would be
surprised to play games at 1080p or
lower resolutions that are like
completely maxed out I think they would
be surprised at how great that
experience is compared to an experience
where it's just more pixels so with that
being said like pushing to 8k to me
sounds like a terrible idea we can't
even get 4k running at
thirty frames per second for a lot of
the games coming out
I played the Resident Evil a demo on my
PC I played it in 1080p but I maxed out
all the graphical settings and that game
looked ten times better than any 4k game
I've ever played so it's it's not as
easy as more pixels means better you can
play an indie game you can I can make
Tetris in 8k having more pixels for
Tetris doesn't get me excited you got to
do things with the the power that's more
than just pushing pixels onto the screen
and I think even playing games like
shadow of the Tomb Raider that have
multiple settings you can do 4k you do a
framerate you can do like a texture kind
of one switching between them you might
realize that 4k isn't always the best
option for some games it is a fantastic
option and I'm very much a proponent of
like driving the technologies to get us
where we're going
and I'm not saying 4k gaming was a bad
step or we should have never taken it
it's definitely a step we need to take
and I'm glad the Xbox 1x is powerful
enough to do 4k for those who want it
but at the same time I don't like
pushing pixels onto the screen isn't
always the most important thing in my
opinion this is a this is something I
doubted a lot back in the txr days
everyone was just so focused on pixels
pixels pixels but yeah man like a gaming
I think we're getting ahead of ourselves
EK gaming is four times more than 4k
gaming and 4k gaming is not something we
can really do that well either a lot of
people who have you know pcs that cost
$10,000 they're still playing in 1440p
because it doesn't always make sense to
just drive more pixels to the screen
nonetheless
oh I digress look man I don't know when
I'm given the option I always go for
like the higher textures and the
particles and all that stuff and the
frame rates most importantly over just
pushing pixels to my screen but you know
everyone's different and everyone enjoys
different aspects of the game of games
and I don't think we should be thinking
about 8k yet personally but it's always
cool to see like CES like thinking way
ahead of the curve
yeah and I think that that's what it
comes down to right thinking way ahead
of the curve and then thinking about
what advances in tech can we show off to
push the product in a way that makes it
you can see the differences right and so
you can sell it to the average consumer
the gamer like you said the gamer may
care more about 1080p 60 frames per
second or 120 frames per second the
average consumer that they also trying
to sell this 8k TV to only wants to see
how pretty it is
right so it's just one of those things
where I think it's it's it's a type of
advancement in tech that shows well
right well let me say something that I
love personally that not many people I
think have really talked about that
might be just unique to me so apologies
going in but one of the things that I
really liked in the PlayStation 4 and
the Xbox one era was I really loved the
crossover generation games I really
think that developers in video games
tend to push things as far as possible
until you wind up in 25 to 30 frames
land and so since that was where they
were pushing things to get it on the
PlayStation 3 in the Xbox 360 working
correctly I think that that made the the
the resolution the graphics the
performance all the more solid and
better at the higher generational level
so I love those crossovers and I agree
in terms of resolution isn't the be-all
and end-all I tend to lean towards
resolution over framerate in things like
god war but the one place where I really
would love to see resolution 'el
increases is in the VR goggles
I heard you referenced Tetris but if you
gave me an 8k Virtual Reality Tetris
effect right now you might not ever see
me again you live in your best lives
that deck game makes you have a long day
you're fighting with people on the phone
they're telling you you're terrible at
your jobs which is the day of the lawyer
so you don't law school kids is you you
get back you put on Tetris effect you
listen to some cool tunes if that was it
just slightly higher resolution I think
that that would be the perfect game mm
fair enough right oh Lord King you're a
very premium gamer so
the tradeshow let these stuff
listen half the people that they play
video games you're playing on simples
and basic systems I know you do this is
the year we will keep it fair and that's
listen y'all got an even upgrade past
ten y'all still rockin 720 televisions
and looking at digital foundry like I
can't believe that spot shut up the
bougie behaved the only thing that I
walked away from the trade show with was
the 5g now the 5g thing that's gonna get
your wallet
remember when 2g was a thing and then
y'all went to 4G and then your bill went
up yo bill gonna go up again bro like
soon your bills don't look like a car
note all right and I want you to
understand you will have a Lexus in yo
on your phone your phone will become
Alexis all right
yalla is so much trouble step yo job
game up your job game oh you've got to
become like hos and become that lawyer
that money can come around listen um
trust me I know you're not gaming all 4k
televisions have we all a gaming Arnold
TCL televisions keep it a hundred
percent real cuz he said a K and it was
like
you know no do not alright listen the
more the thing that's really gonna
affect us and it's far as streaming
because you want to get these streaming
boxes and stuff like that for these next
consoles from these companies like
Verizon and Amazon and Microsoft and
Sony as well is the 5 g 5g is actually
what's going to allow us to stream in
and so you don't see the difference from
disc to UM streaming so that is more
what we should be gearing ourselves up
for uh what we should be saving our
bucks for what we should be looking out
for us that a ke gaming please listen no
that's not a thing it's it's uh you see
the problem that your systems are having
now trying to push the the 4k 30 frames
per second and you see the frames
dropping and sometimes you can get up to
what the 1440p um I think the sweet spot
in gaming and should be 1440p 60 frames
per second we're all effects long and
when Adam with that okay and that should
be what they should target these next
systems shouldn't be targeting no a K
don't please don't do that
um and don't target something that's not
realistic let's have a better gaming
experience right let's let's push for
that I'm with um oh and Mark on this
let's let's push for a better gaming
experience I'm opposed to pushing pixels
that is not realistic now for you can
and I'll double down on ya man it's just
one of those things that obviously when
you hear all this news and stuff like
that I'm a I'm a big-time techie so I
love to see you guys comes around you
get to hear all the stuff so I go to
solve and say hey what happened you know
that kind of deal and you know the
things that I took from it you know a ke
to me you know they're trying to be
ahead of the curve at the end of the day
I don't think it's ready to be
implemented in any fashion just yet as
far as gaming is concerned again I agree
with marketing sense that I I don't I
don't fault them from pushing 4k with
the Xbox 1x but as we know there's not a
ton of 4k 6
right we got to be real about that
there's mostly it's mostly in that 4k 30
range and a lot of it just comes down to
it being you know CPU holding it back so
I really care about what the next
generation of consoles is that 4k 60
sweet spot and the CPUs are buffed up
from the current Jaguar chipset that's
in the UM the Xbox 1x so to me that is
the pinnacle that I need you know saying
I don't really need to see anything else
outside that if they're able to
implement ray-tracing
great but I've heard you know shout the
long breaths and because other people
have said that this is and they may look
at that trade-off and say that that's
not worth it right now at this stage of
the gen and the other thing I just want
to say in reference to the AMD Kino
obviously we saw fail come on stage so
we can pretty much guess off right you
know that partnership is going to
continue as far as the unaccounted next
generation of consoles whatever comes
beyond there exactly so that to me when
I see Phil on stage he's just inferring
that you know this partnership is going
to continue and then we know Sony's in
the building real quick I'll solve did
we hear about that whole you know AMD
created Navi for Sony Playstation 5 bit
yeah I mean it's just talked about
around that basically saying that uh
higher upset at AMD were not happy with
rising and and it came from the fact
that basically the 18 was pulled to work
on Nabi specifically for Sony and the
next-generation PlayStation so we don't
know how true this is and I guess we
won't have any point of comparison until
we have an idea what Microsoft has in
talks well or what Sony has in their box
so you know it's all speculation but
it's it's fun to talk about from the
less the one thing I'll add about 5g is
like it's pricing and marketing strategy
is going to be super simple it's going
to just be 5g for 5 G's on a 2 years
probably the thing I'm most excited
because I suspect obviously you know
Xbox I'm very curious about the project
X cloud initiative I think if they are
able to lock that and I've said this
many LPS if they're able to lock that in
if they're able to prove that that
technology is vile
and hit those markets that traditionally
cannot get an Xbox console in and they
use mobile they use the TVs and if 5g is
part of that equation and giving us less
than low latency experiences with these
as your server forms man this could be
exciting you know so that's one thing
I'm very curious about you know and see
how that works and they're saying right
now like one 3G and 4G that they're kind
of confident at the current state so
it'll be interesting to see I don't know
how you guys feel about that Lord Holger
about the old and Lord Makkah about the
whole lot of 5g in reference to a
project x cloud anything about it okay
Christopher Hart bless your heart
I'll give it to you King let me let me
let me guess off yeah yeah news let me
close out real quick about South to
Sandra Prescott in the chat cuz you
mentioned something that I got I looked
over yeah
another big thing is HDMI 2.1 it's gonna
be a lot of TVs 4k TVs coming out now
with HTT HDMI 2.1 support and obviously
the increased bandwidth is gonna help
with uh basically you know improving uh
colors and again improving the size of
the throughput of HDMI so that's that's
interesting and another thing that I
forgot to mention what the heck was the
other thing
well let me just talk real quickly the
Ailee Ailee where's OLED gaming monitor
HDMI two point one four K at 120 Hertz
that is my thank you for your wish lists
they hit up the iron bank for his
alright I thought we got to go back we
were killing this thing all right we all
know to Sony success numbers have come
out at least you know we'll do it real
quick man tremendous success ninety one
point six million PlayStation fours old
whoa why how is that possible there's
only seven million people
[Laughter]
the last update in July 18 million over
the past twelve months and then
obviously to Lord Kings happiness the
ps4 exclusive of Christmas was
spider-man with more nine million copies
as 52018 much to Lord addicts chagrin
I'm sad he cannot be here than here Lord
hold me Lord mocking it with the best
between Lord King and Lord addict and
reference to you I'm wearing the red and
we have a segment called bend the knee
and forced to bend the knee on camera as
a result of him losing the bet so the
last thing I was the PlayStation Network
they continued at the announced that
they had tremendous growth surpassing 90
million active youth at the end of that
with over 20,000 18 so Lord King I'm
gonna start this with you thank you a
lot to say about these matters and then
we'll get a panel get out of here what
do you feel about these are Sony
announcements Christopher bless your
heart you know when we go to the next
generation you start from zero right so
that 91 is not going anywhere with you
bro go so all that you talk about they
got the message they don't have anything
they go to the school with zero go
Said's so use that hope brother and hope
is what she needs all right now back to
facts brasstacks a day of his selling
and they did it they appealed it to the
cheap gamer the hilt reader to the
wallet conscious dude walked in and he
had $400 and it was a $500 console he
said I'm gonna go with the 400 okay so
we all know that was way I went down
with
you could say bad message in we're gonna
go with cheat gamer that's and I
understand if Microsoft was at the same
price maybe that would happen because
they have more games oh yes right before
we're uncomfortable maybe with the
camera facing them at all times over
there you know that was a troll that
they put inside you know how you tweet
so and the stuff start spreading like
wildfire like like tomorrow you're gonna
find out that Activision is under
investigation for fraud oh wait a second
and Bungie got out at the right time
that's not real whole just broke it down
to you exactly what it was it was some
minor thing and stuff just blown out of
proportion
it's cool we don't play sales figures or
numbers none of us here or on Sony's
board as far as I know I didn't get a
check yet at all so all we doing is
marketing that stuff and that's great um
listen I hired them alright so when I go
purchase a game I'm putting them to work
if they do not perform in my house they
get out X Cognito he purchased one of my
pros from me okay you didn't perform
only one yeah pretty one had experiences
guy no it's just I guess so what every
week we gotta hear oh this week we sold
two hundred mil and then their family
just like a moccasin he doesn't care who
buy trials trials is coming out in
February and he's gonna buy trials and
he's gonna enjoy trials Gaming is a very
selfish experience until you go into
multiplayer stuff we don't really care
where we get again from I could play on
a taller bow literally with two
controllers literally it could be a
toilet bowl and I did with the Jaguar CD
oh we did not care so please we just
start with this you know holding down
the fort
there's no four to hold down you just
being cheap you just didn't buy another
system that's all your financial
situation dictates your dedication
then it so you try to say king that if
in a perfect world if gamers had the
resources to attain both that things
would be different if you think this
can't this comes down to purely
financial situation everybody probably
on this panel right now have multiple
ways to game through your cell phones
you know so um we upgrade ourselves to
play a better version of Tetris but we
we love games so we're gonna play all
over the place financially you like like
like maca say when your friend had a
system you too had that system back in
the days because we didn't have the
resources to purchase multiple systems
as you got older you purchase multiple
systems because you didn't want to go
over to his you know his house and wait
for him to pass you to controller oh so
no man his financial situations dictate
that dedication to whatever systems that
you are loyal to at the moment yeah
enough Lord Hogue
want to talk about Saudi success real
quick well I think it's great that
anybody hasn't success at any point in
the industry I agree with King on this
and so far as I do think that in a
perfect world everybody would have
everything and there wouldn't be this
console war type situation I think from
a historical perspective what I worry
about with Sony is that at least for
about three rounds of generations now
we've had essentially the winner
completely fall on their face with what
they plan for the generation following
their bid with the consumer and he says
uh what was your wish your terminology
saw with the day what they they always
find way to snatch defeat from the jaws
of victory and trip and trip over
themselves in a way that makes
absolutely no sense
oh yeah I get haughty so I think I think
seven years or however long the general
and lasts is just enough time for these
brands whether it's Microsoft or whether
it's Sony or whether it's even Nintendo
to some extent with the Wii to kind of
believe their own press clippings and
believe that people just love them for
them and not for whatever their product
offering is and then release something
crazy like the PlayStation 3 or the
initial press conference for the Xbox
one which whatever the six hundred
references to television and that I
think that if I had any concern right
now it's that Sony touting all this
stuff saying we're skipping e3 e3 where
you're gonna travel through a church and
we're gonna show you nothing I was there
it was it was amazing no one knew what
the hell was going on seems to suggest
to me that maybe they're getting back
into their hottie phase and that
PlayStation 5 suddenly have a hologram
person that talks to you that makes it
cost $800 and people don't want versus
what Microsoft's doing and I will always
really like the underdog or the person
without that market position you know
they're backward compatibility
initiative has been utterly unbelievable
how it's been well and that's that's
really cool to see that innovation where
they're in the where the Xbox one was so
vastly underpowered that it's great to
see the ex out there doing great things
that's where I play the majority of my
game right now to seem that backward
compatibility and I instinct is that the
Xbox what I'm when I presently think is
going to be called the Xbox infinite
comes out that it's gonna be what
everybody wants versus the PlayStation 5
which is maybe gonna have some of that
old Sony gristle on it it's turn to mess
up so yeah I would hope I would not put
it past them and then there are certain
things that come out again rumor mill
stuff that I think Cognito Simulink -
this is its name Brad Sam's yeah Breslin
Fred Sam's talk was talking about a
speculation about the RAM that's gonna
be in the PS 5 and he's hearing 16
gigabytes of gddr5 this point is super
expensive and
does not put that console in anywhere
near the $400 range mind you the systems
probably aren't coming out to 2020 so
they could be a reduction in price by
then but we're talking with they're not
looking at trying I at least from that
regulation is true and not looking to
give you a budget conscious console in
addition to that like what you were
saying like you know some having some
sort of like uh some sort of person in
the console talking to or whatever some
sort of weird technology and nobody
wants right also indicated that eight
gigabytes of that Ram would be allocated
solely to the function of the OS which
is irregular and for function of the OS
so what he's thinking is that there is
some sort of underlying thing that's
taking up all of that RAM that isn't
necessarily just to run the normal
day-to-day stuff in conjunction the
rumour is that again who knows yes now
or as virtual reality inclusion and
things that na psvr
yeah I mean again I think would be a big
mistake to try to force VR on people all
right I think that's it that would be a
total bonehead move yeah that's you know
type mistake and there I'm saying that
is someone who absolutely adores VR
mm-hmm that yeah if you force it you get
that extra expensive console in the box
and then suddenly everybody's playing
xbox so that's exactly the kind of thing
that I would expect from Sony's
PlayStation 5 so there you go before I
give it about that going yeah be crazy
oh yeah listen at the end of the day you
know I hear what you guys are saying
they have to they have to have caution
in terms of their hubris right you know
obviously they have dominating work you
know and it's just you know it's one of
those things man with just like you do
watch them you I am concerned that they
skipped III entirely I am concerned that
it's almost it's gonna go about like
twelve months or whatever it's gonna be
without any type of show for their base
you know there's no place get PSX you
know they skipped you know another show
you know I don't know if games cause
whatever it was and um you know you just
want to do something to invigorate your
base so that they know now the vibe that
I get is obviously like Lord Marcus said
you know last year's show that you know
even though the titles were impressive
you know the set up could use a little
work there was only four games they've
kind of showed you know repeated times
in the past so the the consensus is they
didn't have a lot to show so it just
seems that you know maybe a lot of this
stuff is there in between you know the
end of the ps4 generation but yet not
ready to show us the game that in theory
will be on PS 5 so at the end of the day
we have to admit though they do have the
mindshare coming into the generation and
you know obviously this success is
tremendous I mean spider-man I didn't
even see that coming
to be honest I mean I knew it would be
successful I my heart was saying King
was gonna win that bet you know what at
it but at the I didn't think this
successful you don't say like that to me
9 million that's insane you know that's
general that that $200 bundle was the
bundle of Christmas I mean I sold a lot
of spider-man absolutely completely
agree so that's what I got a little
Malcolm allergy and this thing else we
can get out of it what it what do you
think about so many success and you know
moving forward yeah I'll try to go too
long it's great that Sony's doing great
I think a lot of it does have to do with
that hundred dollar price difference
when they first came out a lot of it has
to do with the Kinect being you know
adding to the price of the Xbox and
making the Xbox the less sexy option
because it was more expensive but also
less powerful I think at the beginning
Xbox shot themselves in the foot with
the messaging in the DRM I think that
was the the biggest thing is Xbox not
knowing how to message things but like
right now you know Sony Sony's doing
great decks but it i fat I don't really
have many comments like I think it abs
and it flows and I think next generation
we could see the opposite and then the
generation after that will see the
opposite again and they're gonna kind of
go back and forth we'll see I do oh I
did my biggest kind of takeaway was just
it was very interesting to me to see
like Sony be like 91 million and the
next box goes to billion zombies were
shot
I wish you vodka let's keep a rhythm if
you don't you think that that has to do
at some point if you're not reading the
FEV every bug oh no no no that it's the
right thing to do good saying is
interesting to see the difference of
approach absolutely I do
thank you but no no Xbox is killing it
backwards compatible like Xbox game pass
is legit like changing the world of
gaming there's a lot of really great
reasons like Xbox has been slowly
winning back the confidence of consumers
and I think when people go to make their
next purchase they're gonna think about
all the things Xbox has been doing
properly in the last couple months or
years even and then they'll also think
about maybe they're not so cool things
Sony's kind of been doing and I think
we'll see more people give like a good
consideration to Xbox the next
generation no impasse is amazing I mean
one thing I would add to that is that
yeah I was setting up my father who is
obviously older than me on an Xbox for
Christmas and he was you've had such
warm feelings towards I said hey just
get this game past because you're gonna
be set up with however many games you
want to try out and he had such warm
feelings towards what that was that if
you talk about mindshare there are
people that are maybe not as hobbyist
gamers as we are that are getting in
there buying an Xbox one and saying oh I
can just get this thing I can try out
all these different experiences and feel
really good about Microsoft way giving
way more value than the price of that
license and I really think that's
working out for them certainly on the
margins and certainly may be among the
core as well even I think I think that
is uh could be one of the secret weapons
and we know for sure that they are
definitely pushing hard with game pass
especially with project X cloud alone a
lot of other initiatives that they got
going on so it'll be interesting to see
man this is good stuff shot the kids
moving to chat
he said he blames social media 2017 in
scalebound for Xbox it's boy let's get
out of here man it's the lp poll this
week with the recent announcement of
Bungie parting ways from Activision and
assuming full publishing rights of the
destiny franchise what do you think is
the best course of action for Bungie
moving forward
the choices are a remain independent and
MultiPlan control your own destiny be
hey girl is Phil and Microsoft online
one hope for you let's get ready to get
see change your heart so DS daddy what
really will have us out here living our
best life it needs to be on that list
those choices please rock the IOP dating
gaming pole Isaac yo Lord
maka Lord Hogue an absolute pleasure to
have both of you in the world last very
much appreciated let's start off with
law of mahkum a tremendous tremendous
gaming history and tremendous content in
game reviews Wieck and the fine people
find you yo thank you so much for having
me one thing before I get into my self
promo if you want to like support xbox
the community and stuff there's a huge
halo tournament happening today it's
actually a halo 3 tournament and there
will be tens of thousands of people
watching a halo 3 tournament in 2019
that's pretty dope twitch.tv slash UGC
it's called the halo classic I'm gonna
be watching it tonight and you should
too
was not not sponsored by any means I
just really like halo remain you can
catch me at youtube.com slash maket of
anyone productions twitch.tv slash mac
in anyone productions or on twitter at p
mecca 1991 couldn't find a better handle
than that i make game guides
walkthroughs tutorials achievement guide
strophe guides and the likes
i recently put out a video on after
charge which is recent impact and yeah
thank you so much for having me do
makamaka man when I see the first rounds
on me hopefully I'll see you again at e3
and sure make you doing what you're
doing please subscribe this man's
channel he's doing tremendous work this
is the achievement guide and walkthrough
King like if you want to learn how to
get something in collectibles this guy
is your man as well as great reviews and
he's been doing it a long time
please subscribe this guy it's a
pleasure to have you know hopefully we
get you back on so thanks for having me
lord hope the lord of virtual legaly
dropping gems
and knowledge all throughout the podcast
the chat was enamored with you Lord ho
quick and the fine people find you and
what do you have going on next
yeah well um and I apologize that my
voice is just about done so I'm glad
we're wrapping up I started a YouTube
channel this last year where I do a
little bit of legality a little bit of
virtual to talk about stuff like video
games talk about software and talk about
the business side of the industry as
well so my most recent video was on the
bungee activision split the videos I had
before that talked extensively about the
star control origins and DMCA kerfuffle
a legal technical term and you can find
me on Twitter at Hoag la joie GLA W on
youtube under the same my website and my
blog they're all under the same it's all
ho claw thankfully I have an odd enough
name that I could get that in all major
locations but I love talking about this
stuff and obviously I I like to share
what I know from a legal and business
side of things absolutely then continue
to do what you're doing I mean it's
tremendous work and it's really a
service to gamers to really understand
the legal aspects of it and your
experience in corporate law has been
absolutely tremendous and it is an honor
to have you in here discussing these
things in the realm of the Lord so thank
you thanks for having me
absolute pleasure absolute pleasure Lord
solve where can I find people find you
because we know Lord ho I mean Lord all
actually Lord addict I'm lost empowered
in a so we gotta jump straight into you
but uh yeah wicked if I'm people find
you what you got going on first of all
big shout out to Lord Howe and Lord
Markham okay one o'clock came and things
were kind of touching go man like our
cameras weren't working gonna be a train
wreck of a show and you guys came
through it absolutely of the day for us
thank you so much guys and through
beyond that you guys can find me on
Twitter Lord Saab ILP and on PSN and
Xbox Live BX sovereign real quick we
have a quick reroll shout out to Lourdes
narro for graciously uh paying forward
his teespring winged win so I'm going to
do that really quickly and he didn't
want us to see him in the leggings like
that the new winner of the teespring
giveaway is Lord death singer Wow this
singer you probably receive your
teespring thing by like January
thank you guys go down absolute Lord
King man absolute pleasure you out here
doing doing what you do thank you to our
wonderful guests today hold his family
maka yo fantastic I love the energy and
and bloody bloody
let's get that switch mic up in the car
he begged me to get on this I gotta be
quick man it's a log show yeah listen
we're moving forward a whole lot of
stuff a lot of information is gonna come
out and we're gearing up for packs as
you saw from the beginning of the intro
of the show so we should be have our sea
legs under us this pack so this packs is
gonna go a little bit different all
information is gonna be out there the
website that you heard from the
beginning it's gonna be a with a whole
lot of information and stuff and we're
excited
in this new of 2019 and going forward
with all the stuff that we got for you
guys so we do appreciate everybody that
came to UM I hate yo Chris you know I
love you so fanboy go together yeah
again again shout to Lamont gunshot the
Lord hold on me please hit that like
subscribe you know l'homme a
notification gang y'all need
notification gonna need you I hate that
I'll be appreciated and obviously the
ILP audio will be going up later too
I catch this on Spotify iTunes and
SoundCloud didn't Google Play and all
that good stuff so um check that out and
also imaginary know Laurie bondus and I
our destiny show we have to rebrand we
are the last word so thanks a lot home
for helping us we actually go a little
bit in depth as well as far as the split
and we will continue moving forward with
that and like our Lord King said we got
a lot of things special things planned
for you guys I'm super excited cannot
wait to announce also stay tuned for
episode 100 when that comes because
that's gonna be super special but
everyone that's it I've ran on long
enough
enjoy your Sunday o lot more Marcus got
it in there let me show that yep Lord
twitch.tv let /ug see that's the halo 3
toilet right Oh Marcus eight thousand
people watching it's the finals ladies
thanks again